ces habitants de puiser sont en colère
leur redevance pour le ramassage des
ordures ménagères va augmenter de 25% et
ils ne l'acceptent pas ils ont créé un
collectif et lancé une pétition sur le
net contre cette augmentation
ça passe pas parce que c'est trop
important dans ce coup déjà donc on a eu
10 9 % en 2015
déjà pas mal ceci étant du jeu les
injustes et à dire tout simplement
cesser trop dans ce coup il faut nous
expliquer pourquoi en puisaye forterre
les ordures ménagères sont ramassées une
fois par semaine comme ici à tous si la
communauté de communes en a la gestion
et va mettre en place une collecte des
emballages en porte à porte
c'est l'une des raisons qui
expliqueraient l'augmentation de 25%
mais une partie des habitants comme des
élus sont depuis très remonté à l'image
du maire de maysir qui a voté contre
cette décision qu'il ne comprend pas ça
marchait très bien que ça marchait très
bien comme souhaité le président
essayait de nous justifier sa part les
mises aux normes
le marché a été renouvelé et le marché
de ramassage coûte un peu moins faire
donc c'est pas juste pour ça qu il
justifié
la communauté de communes de puisaye
forterre n'a pas donné suite à nos
sollicitations
mais selon elle l'augmentation de 25%
coûtera 3 euros par mois et par habitant